foreign
[Music]
enhancement has long been the stuff of
myth and science fiction from Adam and
Eve biting into that apple to Icarus and
his prosthetic Wings to the film
Limitless which features a pill that
makes you capable of easily mastering
the most complicated information
proverbial Magic Bullets that modify or
extend or enhance our natural abilities
and help us overcome our weaknesses they
have been depicted as having great
potential to help but also to hurt
Humanity in unpredictable ways and when
it comes to truly enhancing performance
of overcoming our limitations some of
the most promising work being done right
now is in the area of brain plasticity
Cutting Edge research suggests that a
whole arsenal of tools from video games
to brain stimulation to Pharmaceuticals
they may make it possible to rewire our
brains in ways that take our neural
Pathways back to their early childlike
States opening up what are called
critical periods these are periods of
development when our minds are most open
to learning new things conferring upon
us the ability to master new languages
to pick up a new instrument to jump
higher to run faster to overcome
debilitating brain injury to cure
depression possibly reverse autism slow
dementia and help us focus more deeply
but even with such promising development
moments we still do not fully understand
the long-term effects of such
interventions on the estimated 100
billion neurons in the trillions of
synaptic connections within the human
brain so tonight
we are going to focus on the promise and
The Perils of this young and evolving
science which seeks to go beyond our all
to human frailties and limitations by
leveraging our brains incredible
plasticity
[Music]
I'd like to welcome all the scientists
in tonight's program who are doing some
fascinating work in brain plasticity
each using a unique tool to experiment
with opening up critical learning
periods in the brain John krakauer joins
us from Baltimore Maryland where he is
the director of the center for the study
of motor learning and brain repair at
Johns Hopkins school of medicine and the
director of the brain learning animation
and movement lab next we have takao
Hench who joins us from Cambridge
Massachusetts where he is joint
professor of Neurology at Harvard
Medical School and professor of
molecular and cellular biology at
Harvard Center for brain science and
finally we have Brett wingeyer who joins
us from Burlingame California he trained
as a biomedical engineer and over the
last two decades has invented a series
of devices aimed at neuromodulation he
is currently the CEO of a company
developing a transcranial stimulation
device meant to treat depression welcome
to you all so takao if we can just to
get us going
what are we talking about when we use
this term brain plasticity yes in a very
broad sense brain plasticity is the
ability to alter brain function in
response to experience experiences of
any kind but if we step into it a little
deeper as far as the brain is concerned
any ability translates to some molecule
or a molecular basis and brain functions
are typically defined by specific neural
circuits that must be changed and
experience translates into patterns of
electrical activity in the brain so the
general definition I think everyone can
appreciate is that repeated experiences
will shape the way we think the way we
act and that's brain plasticity now John
I gather it's the case that I think we
all have this intuition I don't know
exactly where it comes from but we have
this intuition that there are periods
when our brains are more susceptible to
the brain plasticity that the cow just
described and like later on as we get
older our brains I don't know they kind
of Harden in some sense and aren't able
to respond to the environment with the
nimbleness that they might have or the
dexterity that they might have when
we're young is that the case and and and
what do we know about the periods when
the brain is most open to change yeah I
mean I I will definitely uh talk about
this for a moment although takao has
done sort of seminal work at the
molecular and cellular level on this but
I'm particularly interested in how you
can sort of have these windows of you
know critical period reopened
um by injury but now there are also
people working on sort of more
controlled ways to recapitulate these
critical periods
um later in life pharmacologically maybe
with brain stimulation and and so the
cow yeah
do what do we know about those critical
periods are they specific to certain
learning tasks do they open and close at
fairly well-defined moments in the
development of a human brain well we've
known about critical periods or the
malleability of the brain changing
across development for centuries from
Aristotle to Montessori to the present
day and this comes from careful
observation of children infants and
children and their ability to acquire
new skills at an astonishing rate do you
know an age where that closes I think
this is an important question so
um
there are probably Myriad number of
critical periods is really the important
message that brain function translates
to particular circuits that change
whether you're talking about Vision or
hearing or speaking and so on and so
each one of those could have a slightly
staggered window of plasticity and in
fact there is a sense of hierarchy that
perhaps the primary sensory areas are
first filters to the outside world are
shaped earliest and perhaps most
stringently which then feeds into
multi-sensory areas that integrate the
different kinds of input and ultimately
build up a complex cognitive machine
like the adult brain so I think it's
important to keep in mind that there's
not just one critical period and that
there are sequential on a series of
these that allow for the complex
behaviors that we're capable of and
Brett we're going to talk about some of
the work that you've done a little later
on in terms of trying to manipulate the
brain perhaps harness some of the brain
plasticity that we're talking about but
do you consider the task of trying to
harness brain plasticity a fundamental
Science question or is it an engineering
problem I mean how much detailed
understanding of the brain do we need to
have to be able to harness these
qualities yeah you know it's it's both
and it's one of the interesting things
about this field is you know we we
certainly have ways with technology
where we can we can encourage plasticity
and you know just just to be clear we
it's not just with technology that we
can do that you know as adults we are
all still plastic and we're not plastic
in the same way that our kids are you
know I watch my kids trying to learn a
second language and it's amazing and I
you know I I so I feel that very
personally but um you know the if
um you know we're we're we're plastic
every day and that we we we learn things
as adults and we have mechanisms where
if if we're particularly emotionally
engaged you know they then we we we
learn things better
um now with you know with technology to
encourage and increase plasticity we're
on a journey of learning where we're
informed by uh we're informed by the
basic science we're informed by the
applied science of of how do you
interact with the brain in a better more
targeted way and there's a lot of
there's a lot of interplay between the
fundamental science and what we can do
with technology and in general you know
any any kind of neurotechnology or
neuromodulation whether it's on the
medical side or the um the human
potential side it just gets better and
better the more we understand about the
underlying mechanisms and change things
from basic science questions to uh to
engineering problems where we understand
the science yeah well I certainly feel
your pain on the language acquisition is
I have started to return to playing
piano and my 17 year old son also
returned you know and and I can't I
can't keep up with him I mean he's
zooming ahead he's like five pieces in
and I'm still struggling on one before
so there's definitely something going on
inside my head that isn't as flexible as
I I would have hoped it would be so John
when we think about critical periods and
plasticity
from an evolutionary standpoint do we
have a sense of why it is that the brain
is structured in such a way that it goes
through these periods why is that the
route that Evolution took well I mean
there are all sorts of arguments
um you know it's a big job to get to
being
a fertilized egg to a very large
you know millions of times larger
organism
so there's a job that needs to get done
to set the system up and have it respond
to experience so it gets set up with the
right structure
right but you don't want that runaway
plasticity indefinitely
right I mean there are consequences to
unbridled plasticity
um so it has to be controlled you know
with great power comes great
responsibility right and this is a form
of plasticity that um would not be very
good I mean just like plasticity and the
ability to duplicate in cells if it goes
uncontrolled you get cancer right you
could have you know analogously the same
kind of problem with just morphic tissue
seizure dangers and all sorts of things
like that you know
um the kind of thing that you have to do
once you've reached cruising altitude
and learn
things is not the same big lift as how
you have to get to cruising altitude in
the first place so you need to have
control mechanisms homeostatic
mechanisms in place to keep this in
check
right now it would be very nice if you
could go in and manipulate these
negative feedback loops these
homeostatic control mechanisms so we
could open up under control conditions
but it makes a lot of sense to me that
you don't want these growth
environments to be on indefinitely right
so so DeKalb we are starting to learn
that's really the point of the
conversation we're having here that
there is something new in our
understanding of brain Plastics today
the older idea that we've just heard is
that there are periods when the brain
opens and it kind of closes down but now
I gather there's evidence that we may be
able to reopen brain plasticity in
mature brains and adult brains why
what's the evidence for that and and and
why do we think that may be the case yes
the um novelty and the new insight that
has come about I would say in the past
20 years is twofold
the cellular understanding of what
determines the timing of these critical
periods has become apparent so there are
triggering mechanisms and then likewise
there is a system of molecular breaks
which seems to act in an active way to
close these critical periods and it's
this Insight that's really allowed us to
manipulate the timing and to reopen it
or extend it into adulthood and of
course all of this starts with animal
experiment animal models but in many
instances the findings have been
surprising and translatable based on
pharmacology that's already out there
being used or with a clever inference of
what might be happening in humans as
well and so John you mentioned that
injury traumatic brain injury can reopen
brain plasticity why does that happen
yes I mean you know first of all you
know as cow has also mentioning we've
known a long time that you get most
recovery from all sorts of brain injury
early in animal models and in humans
now you know we I can just mention we
did a very slightly freaky experiment in
the mouse where we basically gave a
mouse a stroke and then delayed its
training and it never really got back to
normal behavior
we found also that if you started the
training very soon after the stroke in
other words you don't wait a week you
wait just a day then the efficacy of the
training was much greater to the point
that you couldn't actually tell the
difference between the mouse is reaching
before and after the stroke now the
really freaky thing is if you did the
original experiment and waited a week
and then gave a second stroke in other
words you actually made the mouse worse
but you now didn't wait you actually
recovered completely from the first
stroke so in other words a very profound
demonstration of being able to
manipulate a critical period by injuring
the brain
right now in terms of
um why that should be the case it seems
to me
um only sort of logical and parsimonious
to imagine that there are repair
mechanisms in the brain right just like
you cut your skin break a bone damage
neural tissue there's going to be some
repair process set in place
that will have some overlap with the
kind of processes going on during
development
um now I'm not a molecular biologist by
by any stretch of the imagination so I
defer to people doing work at that level
like decao to tell us how much overlap
how much mechanistic sharing is there
between the repair mechanisms that are
triggered by injury and what's happening
during development but I think you can
see that there will be some sort of
parsimonious intuition that repair and
building might share some underlying
mechanisms now again the degree to which
you can exploit this and the way that
you can actually potentiate it or even
try and make it happen even if you don't
go early
in other words you have a chronic stroke
patient can you somehow make it look
like they're still early after stroke
that's what's very exciting but you are
saying I guess in principle that
incredibly fast intervention in the case
say of a human who experiences a stroke
may make all the difference in the world
you're saying yeah I mean it's very
ironic you know I wrote a whole book
about this several years ago and you can
go back over 75 to 100 Years of
literature in primate and rodent models
and an alien from outer space I actually
say this would look and go why on Earth
wasn't this road taken
right even before we knew the mechanisms
I mean we essentially to this day
um give homeopathic doses of
Rehabilitation early after stroke in
other words if you have a stroke you'd
be better off being a rodent than a
human in terms of the care that one
currently receives so I have made a big
effort to try and introduce intensities
of doses of a particular kind of
Behavioral intervention early to try and
see if humans can have these very
dramatic improvements that have been
seen going back a hundred years in
primate models and you know a little
less but nevertheless dramatic
improvements in rodent models so
absolutely it seems to me that we what
we have to do is to go much earlier and
throw the kitchen sink at Patients right
so so Brett you also have been
developing tools to
manipulate the brain in a manner that
would help reopen critical periods and
not through not through pharmacological
interventions which we'll talk about in
a little more detail in a moment not
through brain injury but through brain
stimulation so can you tell us a little
bit about what that is and what you
found yeah absolutely and before I
answer that I just want to Echo Echo
what John was saying there you know it's
it's absolutely true that in in rehab
you know the the dosing is the dosing is
way off and there's the potential to
have such so much more powerful effects
from you know from a from a proper dose
and really immersing in that rehab and
you know again going back to uh you know
the example of
um you know why our kids can learn piano
so much faster than we can part of that
is you know part of that is because of
plasticity and part of that is because
at at that point in life you're able to
just be so much more immersed in it but
that makes a powerful statement as to
you know what kind of training and you
know in the stroke model what of rehab
is really appropriate but then you know
to get back to neuromodulation yeah I've
spent uh spent about two decades now
um Building Technology to stimulate and
uh stimulate to enhance to treat the
brain mostly on the medical side I've
worked in epilepsy in um done some work
in Parkinson's disease cluster headache
and now at Magnus Medical in a new
treatment for depression but then on the
on the plasticity and Human Performance
side at a company called Halo
neuroscience and you know the the the
the the the mechanisms behind plasticity
are are complex and they're they're
better understood by my colleagues takao
and John here but because there's this
electrical component to
um you know to to to to brain activity
and an electrical component to what to
uh creating plasticity and and we think
enhancing plasticity uh with you know
with neurostimulation elect electrical
nerve stimulation whether it's pulses
that are timed or or waveforms that are
geared to interact with this underlying
brain activity it's possible to modulate
plasticity now you know with with
anything with the brain the the effect
size can be can be small it can be
moderate and it has to be paired with
with the right with the right training
activity to be effective right and and
and so like how strong are these
electrical signals I gather they must be
minute but at a sufficiently high level
that the brain actually feels something
yeah and you know neurons neurons are
very sensitive Detectors of of
electrical Fields because that that's
how you know that's how neurons work you
know cell membranes are amazingly
sensitive now you know that at the micro
scale you don't need a lot of energy but
at the macro scale you know you step
back and you're you're interacting with
the brain you know let's say through a
wearable device well you you need a
certain moderate amount of electrical
electrical current or electrical field
if you're it magnetically then you need
a um you know a strong fast current
pulses to induce the right fields in the
brain and so on but but at the at the
micro level and neurons are amazingly
sensitive yeah so John you've also
developed a wearable
device that as I understand it is meant
to try to be a therapeutic regimen for
stroke victims where they play a kind of
video game where they use their arm to
direct emotion of a dolphin I'd like to
talk about that but let me just show the
audience a brief clip so I have a sense
of what that game is all about the way
the experience works is the 3D tracker
tracks your body position and it tracks
your hand and we're able to map
kind of any direction you're pointing or
moving in whether it's come here or go
far or go up or down into the animal so
you can literally control it in any kind
of way within the entire 3D space
I am dolphin two is a neuro restorative
neuro animation experience that we built
which exploits the residual nervous
system after brain injury through a
combination of high intensity high
dosage and something which we call
dexterity or creative exploration which
we think engenders a kind of cortical
stimulation or or brain stimulation that
helps recovery so the game is you embody
a dolphin it's kind of simple in the
sense that it's a series of battles or
dog fights you do with fish and sharks
but what it's really designed to do is
give you the sense that you've become a
dolphin that you've kind of jacked into
its motor system you're learning the
Dynamics of the dolphin and exploring in
its world how you move becomes a kind of
foreign puzzle where you're trying to
understand the physics of the dolphin
the hydrodynamics of the water and when
you learn that you're able to then
Target fish and sharks and eat them
if we lose the functionality or the
ability to do something because of brain
damage how can we get to a state where
we're exploring again where we're
learning again
so John just running instance of your
motivation for this game is it coming
from more or less what Brett was saying
regarding immersion into an activity is
that the power of video game technology
this is a long story I'm going to try
and compress it yes thank you um um I
think
that this game
um was the
represents the Confluence of multiple
observations in humans and in animal
models
one way to think about it is that
there's been 75 years of work on what's
called enriched environments in other
words you put rodents in a cage full of
ramps and balls and toys and friends and
places to explore you get multi-scale
changes
in the nervous system and the rest of
the body okay one
but that notion of enrichment which is
still very much investigated but it's an
emergent phenomena you can't zero in on
just one thing to explain it it's a
multi-scale phenomena
has never really been tried in humans
surprisingly
second as I said before you need to do
much higher Doses and intensities of
particular kinds of training
because you need to sculpt the
plasticity especially in this
post-injury critical period
you need to maybe make it enjoyable and
social
I mean that's very important too so
you're immersed
so the question was how do you translate
the enriched background and the high
intensity High training foreground into
a simple experience that takes somebody
out of the reality of their injury
all right so and then of course there's
this notion most importantly of
combining cognitive challenge
cardiovascular exercise and skill
learning simultaneously with a full body
experience
now there's a lot of I can say about
this but basically that was the idea is
you have to find a way of doing a
training regimen that has all those
factors that is focused on capacities of
the nervous system not on tasks of
everyday living because you want to
avoid the curse of task specificity
which is what happens when you learn
particular tasks so you want to sort of
trick the system into upgrading General
capacities
all right and you're more likely to be
able to do that in a critical period
than outside because outside of a
critical period the muted plasticity
almost always is Task specific
all right so that was the idea all right
an immersive environment recapitulating
animal data making you be both
cognitively motorically and physically
challenged and then do it at high dose
and high intensity and have you been
able to take patients like within a day
or two after suffering a stroke and put
them into this environment have you done
that um yeah that's a great question so
we did a
um a pilot study first of all trying to
do this in the current Healthcare System
and offer many more hours in addition to
regular rehab is a massive challenge so
in fact in our pilot study which ends up
showing the dolphin was twice as
effective as a regular rehab right we
had to do it about three weeks
post-stroke which is when in our other
work the window begins to perhaps close
a little bit but it was just
logistically too difficult to give that
much I mean they're covering with an
hour in the morning hour in the
afternoon time on task five days a week
for three weeks imagine having a squash
lesson 20 twice a day every day five
weeks or three weeks okay so we did it
but it was after they had been
discharged from acute rehab in New
Zealand now we have a much larger trial
ongoing where they are being enrolled
after about a week of their stroke so
that's very exciting but that's going to
take you know we've only had about 22
patients enrolled it's 150 patient study
but yes the patients can tolerate it
they love it and it's effective
okay and I think we're going to hit a
Tipping Point where these kind of
immersive technology inflected
interventions will take the burden of
therapists to have to try and give such
high intensities and high doses and
allow them to do what they're good at
which is just to learn compensatory
um strategies to do task by task so
takal we're going to talk about your
pharmacological interventions in just a
moment but I want to just stick on the
theme of immersion do you also in your
work find evidence that the kind of
immersive experience that both Brett and
John are talking about is also vital to
plasticity from your perspective oh
absolutely and it's not just our work so
if we think about children they are very
plastic and they learn things very
quickly but the reality is that
immersion and attention arousal are
extremely important components of this
and so in work that was done at the
University of Washington in Seattle for
example infants were brought into the
laboratory American infants who spoke
English at home to interact with a
native Chinese speaker and it was found
that those children in their critical
period several months of age were able
to acquire or more accurately retain the
ability to hear native Chinese speech
sounds with a fairly modest amount of
exposure 30 minutes three times a week
four or five weeks
but what was so brilliant about that
study was that they also filmed and
audio taped the sessions and they had
two other groups of children who were
brought in to only hear the audio tape
or watch the DVD essentially receiving
exactly the same input that the children
who had the live interaction were
getting and neither of those groups were
able to discriminate native Chinese
speech sounds after the same amount of
exposure and so the manner in which the
infants are exposed that serve and
return interaction which is somehow
rewarding to them in the live setting
was instrumental and so there's an
active component of motivation arousal
and attention that seems to be important
even in the most plastic moments during
the critical period so it's no wonder
then that John's approach in the adult
post-critical period brain requires all
this effort I wonder what implications
that might have for things like online
education and even doing programs like
this in sort of a digital delivery
system but we'll put that to the side
for the moment um fascinating uh study
the one that you just mentioned to Cal
but but Brett
um a few years ago as you mentioned
already you were developing a device
called Halo which as I understand it was
a stimulation device that the user would
wear and in that setting it wasn't so
much therapeutic right I gathered was to
try to enhance the performance of um was
it athletes I think that was one of the
applications what what did you find
there and and are there concrete results
that you can point to showing the
efficacy of stimulating the brain when
trying to learn to do something yeah
yeah so so that that device was uh was
called Halo Sport and it was a a brain
stimulator for athletes and musicians
but you know really anybody anybody who
was in gay aged in in training to uh to
to to to have better movement and
um you know that's that goes goes beyond
just athletes and musicians certainly
but uh the underlying technology was
transcranial electrical stimulation so
specifically a type called transcranial
direct current stimulation and that puts
a it puts a small electrical current on
the surface of the head and enough of
that makes its way through the scalp and
through the skull that it um it changes
the it in a uniform way it changes the
electrical fields around the neurons and
uh you know there's still some learning
yet to be done around what exactly the
mechanisms are but part of plasticity is
this saying that when neurons fire
together they wire together now if you
if you dive in in a little bit more
specific way there's there's certain
timings of one neuron firing and causing
an output in the in the postsynaptic
neuron and when you shift that timing
around to some extent then you you can
you can modestly increase plasticity and
that's the that that's a a lot of the
underlying mechanism now the the there
there were
um there were great results not just
from us at Halo but from uh you know
some some colleagues in Academia doing
similar things
um one of the you know one of the best
studies in um
uh in uh in improving movement and it
was a study from the UK that looked at
um you know what you call motor Synergy
and motor sequence and basically
basically your ability to to fire the
right muscles at the right time and the
right amounts together and then to
string that together into into a
sequence of movements which as a again
yeah they're all these parallels to
music you know motor Synergy is making
the chord and then motor sequence is
stringing together the chords in the
right sequence
so you know there's a there's a body of
work that shows um in in good sham
controlled studies shows nice results
um and shows that we can we can increase
plasticity but yeah I've said the word
moderately a few times and that's
because so much about how something like
this works it depends on it depends on
um careful rigorous training it depends
on training thoughtfully so that you're
so that you're training the right things
and you're not um you know I think John
phrased it better better than yeah
better than I am here but when you're
you know when you're engaged in
um trying to increase plasticity so you
can have some you know effect on
learning then
um you know whether that's through a
rehab program or whether it's with a a
brain stimulation technology that that
modulates plasticity
um you you want to make sure that you're
um you know you're you're improving in a
thoughtful way pairing it with good
training and you know creating more more
Global capability and instead of you
know something that's very this is very
you know maybe a very task specific
adaptation so and I read somewhere and
um I'm sure you can tell them the
details that some professional football
players use it I guess some from maybe
even the Oakland Raiders and there's one
study I read where one player increased
the vertical jump that he was able to
attain dramatically is that is that do
you point towards something like that as
the evidence for how powerful this can
be yeah so you know on the on the sports
side there was um we had we had great
data from the U.S national Ski and
Snowboard team they did a uh a
sham-controlled study with the the ski
jumpers and you know one one thing that
they do they they they're great
scientists over there they they
instrumented everything and they they
they do a training program where you're
you're doing a vertical leap that
simulates the conditions right at the
lip of the jump and how how powerfully
and how smoothly you do that it has a
lot to do with with how much distance
you get in the jump so
um you know that that was um you know
there there were
um reliable uh reliable increases in the
both the smoothness and the power of the
jump
um what in in football the the metric
that you know as you say folks were
trying to increase was was vertical leap
and again you know it's um it it seems
like a very simple thing it's actually
great to train on because it's because
it's so measurable and again it's not
just the it's not just the raw power
it's not just the muscular output
um and here here's where the neural
component comes in it's the it's the the
the power and the the smoothness and how
you fire everything in the right
sequence to do an amazing vertical leap
the player who was you know who had such
dramatic results his name was TJ Carey
and he was uh his player for the Raiders
and um he uh you know it got you know he
I've he dramatically increases the
vertical leap but you know the thing to
highlight there is he did that by by
being really thoughtful about his
training measuring his outcomes
um he was very immersive about it and
all of these things you know whether
it's whether it's
um you know improving performance
plastically with neuromodulation or just
in the Natural State it's it's
thoughtful practice it's immersion and
all these things that come together so
that so that your brain can learn and so
from the outside and part of me if this
uh sounds critical I'm just wondering it
sounds like a very coarse approach to
manipulating the brain to just have some
vague electrical stimulation that's on
the surface of the head
is is is it as coarse as it sounds are
we at sort of such an early change well
at some point we direct that stimulation
in a more precise manner or is it just
enough to have some overarching vague
stimulation and that's all that the
brain needs to respond in the ways that
one would want yeah so you know we're
certainly there's there's a a lot more
to understand and the um the the in
particular about you know how do we how
do we better Target
um any kind of brain intervention but
the key here the key here is that the
focality doesn't come from carefully
placed
transducers or electrodes or whatever
the focality comes from the interaction
between the broader effect and the exact
training you're doing so you're you're
inducing a an effect in you know in a
portion of Cortex where you're you're
making it moderately more plastic and
you know the and then you're you're
pairing it with with focused training
that's exercising exactly the the the
the neurons and the synapses and the
networks that that are that are causing
your effect and that are key to what
you're doing yeah so so take how it is
just following on this theme of
plasticity and learning I mean how well
do we understand the molecular processes
that you made reference to earlier when
it comes to the brain's ability to say
learn new languages or learn how to play
an instrument right and and and how can
we apply that molecular understanding to
sharpen the capacity to reopen critical
periods right so
um of course those examples which you
listed are very complex behaviors which
as I said earlier are probably the
endpoints of a series of plastic events
and so a lot of the work has been done
in the very first or earliest types of
critical periods such as the ability to
see through two eyes and understand why
a lazy eye early in life might lead to
the permanent loss of depth perception
for example and these models can be
studied in animals where it's possible
to investigate the cellular mechanisms
involved and so the interesting findings
have been that um
there are particular types of cells that
are especially important in determining
the time Windows of plasticity and their
maturation is what opens them and
brake-like factors are layered on top of
those circuits and we've talked a bit
about electrical activity in the brain
well that's really the consequence of
the fact that there are only two types
of
neurons excitatory and inhibitory cells
whose dialogue is generating those
electrical impulses and so these
approaches of applying a current from
outside the brain are tapping into these
kinds of fundamentals of of Neuroscience
but the brake-like factors interestingly
raise other cell types of Interest as
well
I'll just go back if it's okay to the
issue of neuromodulation in the brain
that translates to chemicals like
dopamine acetylene choline
norepinephrine and this is a kind of
third player that's layered on top of
excitation and inhibition and it adjusts
the gain or the the communication
between such cells and
interestingly video games are almost
perfectly optimized to engage these
neuromodulatory systems they're
eminently rewarding and they grab your
attention and players are fully immersed
that's what we mean by immersion as far
as the brain is concerned and so
interestingly we've discovered that
there are brake-like factors on The
receptors for say acetylcholine which
dampen the response of neurons to these
chemicals and so if you remove this
break then in fact the adult brain
remains as attentive as in the the
juvenile or immature stage and so that
was done through genetic tricks in mice
but it led to a fairly obvious
experiment that if you in fact can boost
acetylcholine have it linger longer for
example in the brain then perhaps you
could override that break and there are
drugs that do that at such as
acetylcholinesterase Inhibitors drugs
that prevent the breakdown of
acetylcholine and this in fact improves
plasticity in the Paradigm of a lazy eye
for example something which we've taken
from the mouse to clinical trial at
Boston Children's Hospital to try and
treat patients who are older than the
age of 10 to recover binocular vision
and so these are patients if I
understand For Whom for whatever reason
one eye was not functioning properly
during a critical period for the brain
to understand signals that the eye is
presenting to it and because of that
that eye even when it's functioning
properly subsequently doesn't yield the
inner experience that we're used to from
functioning vision and you're saying
that that is something that you've been
able to reverse through opening up a
critical period later on right so the
stress strategy was to extend this
window of plasticity into older
individuals previous Dogma would have
said that it's once and done in
childhood and this would be impossible
but the discovery that there are active
brake-like factors to prevent the
engagement of plasticity allowed us to
do this experiment first in mice and
then attempt a therapeutic approach in
humans and and have you gone beyond a
lazy eye syndrome are there instances
where
both eyes weren't functioning for
whatever reason during a critical period
and then they were able to function
later on can you open that critical
period and restore the capacity for
normal vision if you've lost Vision
entirely early in life that's a much
more severe situation where damage has
happened to the nervous system and would
require more effort to try and restore
But ultimately
a plastic window will be called for to
get to that point and so so John when it
comes to to video games which
perhaps to someone watching this program
they might be surprised at the number of
times we've made reference to them I
mean as most parents when my kids play
video games I have an intuitive reaction
that they're wasting their time and they
should be doing something else and so
your work certainly has made clear that
they can play a role in Therapeutics but
do you think they might even play a role
beyond that in terms of enhancing
healthy brains taking them to a place
that they might not otherwise be able to
get yeah it's a complicated question I
mean
first of all I mean as Wittgenstein
wrote you know it's very difficult to
find what a game is right and I and I
don't think the very same parents who
worry about video games they're not
going to be worried if their children
engage in a sport or physical exercise
but once you develop a video game that
is actually a new form of sport or
exercise which hours is
I think that concern goes away
um I think a addictive app on a phone
is a very different thing from an
immersive new kind of sport okay and the
distinction between a sport a game and
an exercise is interesting right but
they're not the same
okay so once you start thinking that way
you can dispense with most of the
concerns that people have in my view
um now in terms of healthy I mean we've
completed a pilot study
um of the of the minepod dolphin in an
assisted living facility outside
Baltimore for healthy aging because we
know
that being engaged cognitively and
physically is good to maintain Health
after the age of 65 if not before
obviously so there yes and we have
signal it leads to both physical and
cognitive benefits it's pilot data but
I'm sure that
you know knowing that the who have
reported that up to half of everyone
over the over 65 worldwide does no
physically physical or cognitively
challenged activity of any kind
right so there's an epidemic
of just being unchallenged physically
and cognitively at a certain point
So to that degree I think that there
should be an immersive experience on
every High Street
um now how one starts to talk about the
younger generation and how to develop
these experiences to sort of enhance
going to school enhance going on to the
football field you know I I that's an
open question but I would be very
surprised if we don't start to do better
with VR AR immersive activities across
the spectrum of human life you know
health and in disease
um it seems to me obvious you just want
to make sure it's a race to the top and
not a race to the bottom yeah well that
actually was my next question the next
question was look if and we're going to
talk to count just a moment about the
pharmacological approaches to opening
critical periods but we've made
reference to drugs playing a role and
electrical stimulation magnetic
stimulation playing a role if opening
critical periods and immersion immersive
experience is such a powerful
combination it would seem that virtual
reality is the real place where you'd
have the greatest coming together of
those forces so have you have you tried
that have you had a virtual reality
immersive experience as opposed to just
the flat video game yeah I mean Festival
yes we've absolutely played with the
virtual reality version
um you know I have mixed feelings about
what's more immersive in fact
um large screens you know some people
have looked at this as just as immersive
as VR
um VR can lead to
um you know cyber sickness it's you know
in in medical environments having those
goggles on can be problematic people
don't like having them on for hours and
hours which is the doses that we gave in
our trials
um they when you have the screen you can
also have someone coaching you you can
have family members watching
so in other words
you know it's it's you're trading off on
other things there is a slight
infatuation with VR
um I think it has is going to have its
moment I'm actually more interested in
AR where you can actually layer things
on top of reality so you can get the
best of both worlds I'm in the end I'm
agnostic to the empirical data what the
best form of immersion is but you're
absolutely right I think the key point
you made is this combination of
non-invasive stimulation pharmacology in
immersive training experiences is really
going to be very multiplicative and I
think that it's it is the future
um both in health and disease and it's
very exciting and of course VR will
begin to have the killer app once we get
these com these ingredients right yeah
and you know just just to jump in there
for a second and you kind of you know
kind of echo John what you're saying um
you know I I you know there is a lot of
excitement around around VR are and you
know it's a it's a cool technology
um you know I think I think real reality
is still more immersive than virtual
reality
um the fact that you can you can watch a
movie on your phone with a with a four
inch wide screen and you can get
emotionally engaged and cry at the
ending you know that's um you can get
emotionally engaged with the characters
in a video game that you know you're
you're playing on a monitor you know the
fact that that can happen it means that
our our brains are so powerfully good at
having you know having that kind of
immersive response to to any kind of to
any kind of content if it's the right
content
um and that yeah that that's the key
challenge is is having that content you
know having
um having immersive engaging uh
emotionally physically cognitively
engaging content you know that's that's
a challenge in any medium and it's one
of the one of the core challenges of VR
is um it's it's great in theory but it
all has to be based in based in the
content and um yeah and also the The
Experience fitting into somebody's life
and carving out the time to uh to to use
the the technology and and having the
being able to put together that whole
picture
that's really important here which is
um there are two ways to think about
these immersive environments
um one is by an you know
recruiting these neuromodulatory systems
and attention and emotion they're
actually having a direct gain effect on
plasticity mechanisms themselves in
other words that's one way that these
environments seem to be working they are
actually jacking in to the gain on the
plasticity mechanisms like cow mentioned
right
the other thing these immersive
environments are doing is they're just
making it more fun to keep time on task
and to practice longer
right now it just turns out that to get
good at anything you have to practice a
lot and the vast majority of people on
Earth never practice anything very much
right now that's okay that's why we
admire athletes and musicians people
who've just spent all that time at the
sacrifice of everything else
to actually become expert at something
okay
now what I've been arguing others is
that unfortunately if you have a brain
injury
or maybe even if you're aging you're
going to have to become an expert
in your attention to that deficiency
right not the low levels of rehab people
usually get
so then the question is how do you
provide the incentive to have to do the
Absurd amounts of practice that healthy
experts do but you're going to have to
do it just because you're now injured
right and what we're arguing here is
that by through the combination of
pharmacology stimulation in immersion
you can do the levels of practice that
are going to be required to have an
effect
and that there are two mechanisms in
play here just sheer time on task
and these modulating effects on the
plasticity itself it's extremely
important to understand that these two
things are happening at the same time
absolutely so it's a cow let's now let's
now turn to that interplay between time
on task as as John describes it and the
requirement of putting in the effort to
gain the expertise and the relationship
to that to pharmacological interventions
and just to get us going some in the
audience may recall the film Limitless
right a film in which if you recall
Bradley Cooper and other characters they
take a pill right a single pill that
suddenly allows them to use I don't know
100 of their minds making them like
super smart and the film was
demonstrated at one point by one
character not putting in the time of
tasks that John referred to but rather
one character takes the pill and reaches
an absolutely stunning intellectual
achievement let's take a quick look when
he told me about this amazing new drug I
was like Down the Hatch and it was it
was amazing
you know I read Brian Green's the
elegant Universe in 45 minutes and I
understood it well there you go right
reading my book in 45 minutes and then
understanding it right my mom put in 45
minutes got to the acknowledgments and
that is as far as as she wanted to go
but but the serious question of course
is to come
you know what are we able to do with
drugs with pills in terms of reopening
these critical periods making the brain
more plastic yes so um the approaches
that have been working so far are
um I would say opening a permissive gate
for learning but you still have to put
in the work and so uh we have done uh
very interesting study with colleagues
at the University of British Columbia
where inspired by animal research where
we lifted the brakes on epigenetic
controls so I can explain that um bit
more the idea is that critical periods
might eventually wind down because Gene
programs are closed and no longer
available for plasticity so one one
strategy was to open them again with
pharmacological tool and there are such
drugs which are actually used clinically
for mood disorders and if we give such
drugs to adult rodents for example we
can rescue their lazy eye condition for
example so because the the drug is
clinically safe and well tested we were
able to design a study of just two weeks
of exposure to the drug or a placebo
unbeknownst to the subjects and during
that time we had them go online and try
a variety of critical period type tasks
such as discriminating native from
non-native speech sounds or identifying
individual monkey faces which babies and
children and do well because they care
but as adults we don't care as much and
they're all lumped into one category
another was absolute pitch the ability
to detect the pitch of a note without a
reference tone
these are skills that if you don't
acquire them before the age of seven you
would lose and so some languages like
Chinese relying on tones retain a high
level of absolute pitch capability or
musicians certainly who've been training
since childhood but the average adult
who hasn't had that experience cannot
acquire absolute pitch after those ages
and so with just two weeks of exposure
thankfully perhaps we discover that the
adult brain is very tough to change and
even if they were on this epigenetic
drug not much was altered except we
found absolute pitch performance improve
and these were subjects who had no
multilingual background or musical
experience before and so highly unusual
to see with just two weeks of training
and this forced us to go back and see
why is this possible and um we think
that perhaps the absolute pitch was the
most stringent in its design perhaps
inadvertently and it might be well worth
revisiting a language task if you want
to learn a second language or the
ability to hear a second language
with more stringency and um
the point is that these pharmacological
tools are really just opening the gate
for
intensive training and as was mentioned
before this is what gives the
specificity of the outcome and which
drugs are I mean is this like Prozac
Paxil I mean antidepressants is that
what right so the drug in this
particular study is a histone
diacetylase inhibitor which is a
mouthful but um valproic acid was used
and it's used in mood disorders in fact
um so these otherwise healthy
individuals in fact
for safety reasons were also sampled uh
in their blood content but also answered
questionnaires about their mood among
other possible side effects and even
their mood improves significantly being
exposed during this trial so they are
clinically available drugs already and
of course we can probably do better with
more specific versions in the future and
so doing Vision a time when if an
individual wants to learn something new
you know an instrument a language
mathematics physics whatever they'll pop
a few pills before they go in to the
class in order to absorb the material
more fully well certainly this
possibility is out there and I'm sure
many college campuses are already
dealing with this kind of situation
there is most recently in this category
of thinking the use of psychoactive
drugs as a way to reopen critical
periods there was a very nice study from
Hopkins in fact that published evidence
of a social critical period in rodents
and that this window could be reopened
by the drug MDMA or ecstasy and and so
this is not to Advocate rampant drug use
but it's to show a proof of principle
that with a very well-measured
hypothesis-driven approach we might be
able to tap the neuromodulatory systems
that are dampened with age through this
enhancement but that alone is not going
to produce plastic change it requires
the training to go with it absolutely so
so Brett sticking with this theme of of
mood disorders and their relationship to
brain plasticity I know some of the the
more recent work I guess you may be
doing this right now you made reference
to it you've been working with a company
to take your transcranial direct
stimulation as a therapeutic tool I
gather for depression can you tell us
what's that about how are you going
about it and what you found so far yeah
so so there's there's a company called
so just to to be clear there's a company
called flow Neuroscience which is
carrying forward Halos technology which
is transcranial direct current
stimulation and they're they're working
on using that in psychiatric disease
like depression now my current company
is Magnus medical and at Magnus we're
using a different kind of brain
stimulation which is transcranial
magnetic stimulation it's a it's an
electro it's an electromagnetic coil it
looks kind of like a figure eight that's
the the physical layer so to speak but
um you know like like any kind of
neurotechnology the
um the key is where are you stimulating
and what is the pattern that you're
stimulating with and what we're what
we're working on bringing to the world
is some technologies that was developed
at Stanford University called the the
saint treatment which is um it's it's
powerfully effective because of a
combination of personalized targeting
that's uh you use functional MRI to
figure out exactly which part of the the
cortex of the brain is is most closely
connected to the deeper networks that
are associated with the symptoms of
depression and then you stimulate that
with a with a series of pulses and
session timing and whatnot that's that
powerfully leverages the underlying
neuroscience and in in the data to date
including a good randomized controlled
trial it's 80 to 90 percent uh remission
after five days of treatment in folks
with really uh um very medication
resistant depression and does that last
is that is that have they followed that
over a sufficiently long period of time
yeah so there's there's good data out to
the six month point and um in if for for
many you know depression is episodic so
for for many people
um you know that that pushes them out of
episode and they're they're well
um either in the long term or until the
next episode uh there's a population
that relapses faster and we're Gathering
data in that but that that also gets to
one a theme here where
um any kind of
neurotechnology or
um you know intervention that's helping
people be more plastic or learn better
or or treat a disease it's
um there's this sometimes challenging
question how do we make sure that this
is relevant and it works in the long
term that said I think there's a lot of
room for optimism because
um when when we learn something and when
our brain changes especially if that's a
an Adaptive as opposed to a maladaptive
thing it then it they were fairly good
at you know we learned something and it
sticks around
um and in a lot of fields of
neuromodulation for medical purposes
whether it's epilepsy whether it's uh
stimulation for movement disorders like
dystonia
um and yeah I think other fields going
forward the the stimulation actually
gets better over time if you use an
implantable brain stimulator for
epilepsy you're getting way better
results a couple years down the road
than you are when it's first implanted
even and you know part of the that is
you know the the the the physician gets
better at personalizing the technology
and setting it up for that individual
but another part of it is um the the
brain learns and it learns new patterns
of activity
um if you're uh uh you know if if you're
using some kind of intervention like
that and so the saint treatment this is
different from the the currently FDA
approved magnetic stimulation this is a
different protocol or a different dosage
has it different from what's been out
there already yeah so it's a it's a
different it's a different treatment
pattern and Technology you can compare
it to
um you know there with with any kind of
Technology there's the physical layer
and you know that's the the bits and
bytes that are passing between us right
now and then there's the the content and
that's the the words we're saying and
the thoughts we're exchanging so you
know that that's that's the core
difference is the is the the
personalized targeted treatment
technology now that that efficacy sound
incredibly good right uh did you
anticipate that level of success is that
a shocking level so you know to to me
um you know I'm the I'm the late Comer
in the project
um you know I'm now the co-founder and
CEO but uh this was created by a team at
Stanford University and they they dug
into
um you know what we know about the brain
and about depression and about the
networks that are involved and uh step
back and tried to engineer every part of
that treatment to make it more effective
so those things certainly made sense to
them and I you know I think they were
you know they were really um you know
gratified and you know surprised as we
are all in this field because the brain
is complicated
um that that the effect size was so
great now you know for myself as a as a
lifelong neurotechnologist
um it's the most profound effect size
that I've seen in two decades of trying
to interact with brains yeah amazing so
I want to spend the rest of the time
that we have turning toward the future
and I just a couple
topics I'd like to spend a little time
talking about so
uh John you know many in the public have
heard about some of these devices
certainly many have heard of you know
Elon Musk talking about whatever it's
called neuro link and things of this
sort
how does one distinguish between the
hype and the reality how does one ensure
as a consumer in the general public that
you are not being taken advantage of or
perhaps doing something dangerous if
one's interested in experimenting with
these kinds of brain stimulations you
know Brett and I have argued over this
in the past you know I was actually Dead
with my colleagues you know one of the
more cited tdcs studies of skill
learning and healthy subjects right in
the effects side was quite dramatic
back in 2009
now there we were using the tdcs as a
tool to ask a scientific question at
least I was the goal at that time was
not simply to say look we can make
people learn a skill
to a greater degree than sham controls
right
now I certainly believe whether it's BCI
whether it's non-invasive or invasive
brain stimulation whether it's reopening
critical periods pharmacologically when
you're trying to take science which is
very rigorous and try and make patients
better with trials I'm all for it
right and you know I I think that is
very exciting what I don't like
is when premature consumer versions of
these Technologies are introduced
right we don't know enough yet
whether we should be doing this in
healthy athletes or students and it's
very interesting right on the one hand
you know when people are accused of drug
doping in sports they're immediately
with even minute amounts of drug in
their system
you know they're expelled from the games
right
and yet at the same time there's a
double standard that when you have Elon
musks and the others hey let's get this
technology up and running and enhance
humans
right now so
I am extremely worried about a
particular and it's a particular West
Coast
techno-utopianism that America suffers
from
where basically the technological tale
Wags the biological dog
and the real interest is to try and sell
and to try and make money by making
people think they're going to be bionic
or they're going to be like the Matrix
or it's going to be like that movie you
showed
um I I think that we have to be super
careful and spend a lot more time doing
the trials and the science
and yes when there are diseases which
are really refractory to drugs like
depression and the and spinal cord
injury now with you know it you know
with spinal cord stimulation and is
doing amazing things for walking
um yes I'm all for that but I am just in
general very concerned about the
premature jump to consumerism and also
the bad faith of claiming that you're
doing this for medicine but really what
you're desperately trying to do is get
the consumer version right and that is a
trend that I am very concerned about so
so not to get us into a contentious
stance here toward the end but I'm just
wondering does anything that Brett
described here today
make you uncomfortable
I am
there are two ways to be uncomfortable
one is I'm somewhat skeptical about
anecdotes of jumping athletes and skiers
I think that they're I mean you know to
be quite honest big Studies have not
really been reproduced of late in tdcs
and there's been a lot of skepticism
about it
um so it there's the actual effect size
and how reproducible it is and then
whether one should be doing this in
healthy people at all so yes should we
when he talks about what they're doing
in depression I think that's amazing
right there I think
if it's done right and it's really in a
group of patients that really are
paralyzed by their illness literally and
figuratively in the case of depression
yes
but otherwise I I think when it gets to
the healthy subjects there's a bit of a
hype cycle when you get to disease I
think it becomes more rigorous Brett I
have to give you a moment to respond to
that yeah and you know I I think you
know John and I are are actually in
agreement about a lot of things and a
lot of the pitfalls here and you know
the you know certainly um you know one
one thing underlying this is you know
what it it's it is hard to
um it's hard to robustly improve
anything that a healthy human brain is
doing you know what what's the the the
the most complicated most finely
optimized thing that we know of in the
entire universe well that's probably the
human brain and when it's operating at
Peak function
um you know I I I I it's it it it's hard
to have any effect sometimes and um it's
certainly hard to have a profound effect
and you know that's why
um you know certainly when you use these
Technologies to to treat disease there's
uh yeah there's there's a network where
there is some you know there's some
pathophysiology in that Network and you
can identify it and um hopefully you can
identify it or you know maybe science is
on a path toward identifying it and that
gives you it gives you a lot of levers
that you can then pull when you try to
design Technologies to to address that
um you know another another thing you
know kind of stepping back to the the
human performance and consumer
applications one thing that we one thing
that we learned and
um you know saw very powerfully at Halo
over over time especially was there's
um there there's there's a there's an
enormous Poll for this kind of
technology and it's uh it's very very
hard to communicate to uh you know to
especially to to consumers in the world
you know what exactly you know what is
this technology what can it do what
can't it do what what isn't it and you
you know the the whole world in a way
kind of expects it to be
um you know more and more more powerful
and much closer to the Matrix than than
it actually is and
um you know that that was a line that we
we tried to
um you know trade tread it carefully and
be clear about what the technology
couldn't couldn't do but uh you know it
was a a learning experience as to as to
how powerfully the world wants to
interpret any kind of performance uh
neurotechnology as as the Matrix and and
there's and there's huge pitfalls in
that you know we and it and it puts a
lot of responsibility on on anybody
engaged in the field to uh to to to to
try to tread carefully and get it right
so so maybe you can also just weigh in
just so everyone has a voice here on
potential consumer applications I mean
are you bullish on that are do you think
we need to proceed with great caution
should be right I mean what's your take
on where this is going I think caution
is very much called for uh we need to be
careful about this hype as has been
mentioned especially with drugs because
everyone is hoping for that quick fix
pop a pill learn something new and there
are reasons why these drugs are
regulated from a safety point of view
but I I assume we'll talk a bit more
about the risks of reopening critical
periods in a minute I just want to say
that the um the study I mentioned on
absolute pitch was a good lesson for us
it uh you publish something like that it
goes viral and uh to this day I get
emails from musicians or want to be
musicians who want to acquire or want to
shake their absolute pitch somehow when
in fact the purpose was approve of
concept that what we've learned from
Mouse models of brain development does
apply to human biology as well and it's
the the heartbreaking emails that I get
of patients and patient families people
who've had traumatic brain injuries or
searching for ways to recover function
that's the audience we are hoping to Aid
in some way by careful study and so I
too am very very concerned about a
publication or papers that use drugs
that are available freely
and being misused and as I just pointed
out even we don't fully understand what
the optimal training Paradigm is to
achieve effects in one domain like pitch
versus language and so there's still
some research that definitely needs to
happen
and so one we from there take it to
where you suggestively might go which is
when you hear about brain plasticity and
critical periods at first sight it
sounds
come on open them up I want to get back
to my young plastic brain which could do
so much that now is so difficult what
are the potential downsides that
research has revealed of reopening these
periods yeah so I'm reminded of a quote
by Charles Lair a French poet who once
said genius is nothing more nor less
than childhood recovered at will and
trying to refine that uh childlike State
many artists have talked about this as
well but I think the the key in that
quote is at will and the ability to do
it in a regulated way I think there are
two answers to your question what the
risks might be one is at a kind of
thirty thousand foot philosophical level
we've all gone through critical periods
shaping who we are our identities are
formed in childhood and our experiences
are cultural background the languages we
speak the skills we have if we were to
actually be able to reverse all of that
wouldn't we lose our self
everybody hopes to add on to who we are
but there is probably a risk if we could
truly reverse a critical period at a
more cellular level we actually know
what the risks are at some level so
another kind of break was identified in
the early 2000s which is an
extracellular coating around the
inhibitory cells I mentioned earlier and
if you
enzymatically remove them which is a
very invasive thing you can only do in
an animal model the critical period
reopens
this was intriguing and has of course
yet to be applied to humans because he
would need to do something drastic like
inject an enzyme but what we learned is
that these nets are not only closing the
critical period perhaps trapping
synapses freezing them in place so they
couldn't be pruned away as in childhood
but they also protect these cells from
oxidative damage and so by removing the
Nets you've also made the circuit more
vulnerable and an intriguing inverse
correlation is seen in the pathological
tissue from Alzheimer's patients so in
those human brain areas that have
evolved to be more plastic longer that
allow us to do all the amazing things
that animals cannot yet do
those brain regions have less of these
net-like structures and it's entirely
consistent with the idea that lacking
this break those brain areas are plastic
longer well now that we live longer we
realize that the first areas that
degenerate in Alzheimer's disease are
those very same areas that have been
enjoying in plasticity for the longer
period of time and I mentioned we also
manipulated a break on the acetylcholine
system well those mice that have been
made somewhat more human-like are in
fact more plastic in multiple tasks
throughout life but they acquire a
neurodegenerative phenotype after some
time which is unusual for mice whose
cortices their brains are closing
critical periods more thoroughly and so
I think there is a an important message
here that critical periods are a moment
of heightened plasticity but they are
also Windows of vulnerability and if
they continue for too long then you may
in fact incur damage and the the
extended lifespan of humans may be
witness to that that is a sobering
thought that makes so much sense and
yeah I don't know about you guys but my
young plastic brain did some colossally
stupid things and you know we're uh the
the way the way the brain works is is
optimized to and it's optimized to learn
from experience at certain points but
then to to benefit from the you know
from the the weight of that experience
and you know that that's you know like
like many of these things you know
that's something that you know that
we're kind of living as mid-career
scientists now we uh you know we've
um we wouldn't be able to do what we do
without you know without that you know
the kind of progressive tuning of the of
the plasticity curve that lets us
um you know learn and optimize our
brains in in different ways as life goes
on and you know I think you know one one
of the you know getting back to to more
of the themes that we've talked about
here one of the ways to
to um you know craft things that that
let us learn faster
um it comes back to immersive
experiences and and the right kind of
content
um that we experience at the right time
um you know and a lot of the time that
that's more effective
than you know than technology then other
kinds of technological interventions or
or Pharmaceuticals or what have you
I just want to make you know take a big
step back and just I think the real
I think big Point here is that behavior
in other words behavioral interventions
modulated by drugs and Technology
is what's coming back
in other words there's always been a
Magic Bullet desire please let's have a
pill that makes us a helicopter pilot or
pill that will cure our Alzheimer's or a
helmet that will make us a great
basketball player there's always this
impatience this kind of let's make it
quick
right it's very male right and I think
that what the real excitement the real
wisdom here
is to know that you need to put the work
in
you actually have to do the behavior and
you need to sculpt it and then
intelligently modulate on top of that
but as soon as you try and jump the gun
and try and just get it all fast
then what takalso articulated so well
you get in trouble and so hence why I'm
so concerned about giving consumer drugs
and consumer devices to people who
should just put the work in
right they should just practice like
everybody else rather than trying to be
enhanced right let us make the
enhancement where we really need it
which is in the medical space
respect Behavior even in the medical
space and then sculpt on top of that
behavior intelligently with modulation
pharmacological or technological
but you it you you cannot get it for
free and as soon as you try and do that
you pay the cost yeah the the tech the
technological intervention it needs to
be I completely agree it needs to be
layered on top of putting the work in
and you know there's a there's a great
example that I mean I think John John's
you know more of an expert in than I am
but uh it's just super relevant here
it's you know what what are the what are
the effective things that you can do if
you have a if you've had a stroke that's
led to diminished motor function and you
know in in one arm hemaprisis what have
you one of the more effective things you
can do is just something called
constraint therapy where you basically
you put you put your good arm in a sling
and it forces you day by day to to get
more use out of the out of the bad arm
and you know that's it it's it it's
effective and it's so simple and it's a
good example of a lot of these themes
yeah well I think you're all right
there's a lot of fantasizing about what
interventions can do I think Hollywood
certainly pushes this fantasizing to a
yet deeper level with these visions of a
transhuman future and who knows maybe we
are heading toward that but of course as
Yogi Berra said and I can paraphrase
it's difficult to make predictions
especially when they are about the
future so let me just uh finish with one
final question don't try to imagine 50
or 100 years from now but like John
10 years from now if if the research
goes along the trajectory that you
imagine it would if things go really
well where will we be in the kind of
work that you're undertaking well I'm
going to try and distinguish between
what is a prediction versus a desire
right
but I really think that we live in a
world of chronic disease
neurological or otherwise and these are
basically behavioral diseases they're
the deleted diseases of modern society
and so they're not honorary infectious
diseases right you can see it with covet
it's the irony that on the one hand you
had an amazing reductionist biology with
the vaccines in other words you could go
after the virus
but all the people who died because they
were obese hypertensive sedentary
diabetic why didn't we have massive
cures of those suddenly well because
that requires behavioral intervention
what I would like the future to be is
that there will become a point where
doctors and other clinicians will
prescribe
an immersive experience tailored to your
particular deficit in the High Street so
it'll be just as natural to go to that
immersive space as it is to go to a
restaurant or the hairdresser or the
cinema
and that space will be obviously
regulated in some way depending on what
you're going for healthy aging or a
particular disease and there you'll also
get some kind of brain stimulation some
sort of drug infusion and you'll
basically get a kind of brain body
cocktail that will be for everybody
whether it's in the supermarket or the
High Street that's I think what the
future will be but it has to be low-cost
it has to be intelligently protocolized
it has to be moral
right and but that's why I think we'll
go in so we won't have 50 of the world
over 65
basically couch potatoing through the
rest of their life that's what I think
the future will be but it will be
Behavior
first not some magic bullet Brett five
ten years from now work you're doing
where do you imagine it possibly being
yeah and I I feel like we're leaving all
this on kind of a you know note of
really really great optimism here um
because I share a lot of John's thoughts
you know I think also in the next five
to ten years our understanding of the
brain networks that give rise to
um really tough chronic diseases like
depression and bipolar disorder or OCD
even things like PTSD chronic pain we're
understanding more and more about those
networks and I think you know certainly
in a decade there are going to be
treatments that are available to
literally millions of people who suffer
from these and
um and the medications in many cases
don't work very well so
um the the amount of human burden that
that lifts the the amount you know the
the impact that that has on the world is
is really amazing
to come giving you the final word
prognostication about where things might
be five ten years from now well this is
a very exciting time in this field
our appreciation of the biology behind
critical periods I think will give us
new biomarkers to track and tailor as
John mentioned approaches to any
individual especially children we can
improve clinical best practice not using
certain kinds of drugs for example which
might trigger premature critical periods
or if you can track the EI balance
excitatory inhibitory balance in
children who are at risk for autism for
example you might intervene early when
the critical periods are open and hope
for a better outcome with behavioral
therapies and then of course what we've
been talking about in adulthood can we
come up with a very rigorous tailored
yet safe and eventually reclosing of a
critical period in adulthood paired with
the optimal kind of training so I I
think this day is coming soon in fact
many people are already accessing drugs
that is are probably doing this to them
unbeknownst to them and we would be very
very
um
responsible for pushing that in the
right direction by providing the
biological and scientific background for
it yeah absolutely exciting exciting
work and Brett I agree it is an
optimistic vision of the future but it
seems one that might be realistic as
well so John to have Brett thanks so
much for the fascinating conversation
thanks for joining us and best of luck
in your work going forward thank you
very much thanks so much
[Music]
thank you